me
の
[音楽]
me
デザインというと多くの人が思い浮かべるのは
おしゃれなパッケージスタイリッシュのプロダクトポスターに web
そのほとんどが見た目のデザインであるように思います
それももちろんデザインです
しかしいい見た目を作ることがすべてではありません
より良い何か
立場や対象はたようであれ
それを作り出すことがデザインだと
私は考えています
時に
見た目だけでなく人々の行動や心理もデザインの対象となり得ます
1970年代ニューヨーク
治安の悪さは全米最悪とも言われた時代
中でも地下鉄は落書きだらけで汚い暗い
危険
犯罪の巣窟だとも言われていました
ところが
2000年になるとその負のイメージは一変
立役者となったのは裏側正道
という一人のデザイナー
彼は40年ぶりに導入される新車両のデザインを一任され
当時薄暗くて落書きだらけだった車両を一新しました
白を基調とした照明と壁で空間全体を明るい印象に
床は黒色
粒子状の模様をちりばめて汚れが目立ちづらい良い
ドア付近の座席のて釣りには
斜めに仕切りを入れて
電車を乗り降りする際に頻繁に起こっていた
ピッタクリア釣りを防ぐ良い
明るくて清潔感ある空間でしかもひったくりはしづらい
そうとなれば
そもそも落書きをしようという気も
犯罪を起こそうという気も抑えられることでしょう
彼は人々の行動をデザインの力で
よりよく支えたいとの思いで車両をデザインし
実際人々の行動は変わりました
地下鉄内での犯罪の発生率は8割も減少
イメージも回復
10人も観光客も安心して使えるようになりました
彼は言葉を使うでもなく
武力工事に頼るでもなく
デザインの力で
より良い社会を作り出したのです
彼の仕事をした当時私は高校3年生
何の気なしにつけていたテレビで会えのインタビューを目にして
デザイナーはそんなことまで考えているのか
デザインにはそんな力
人の心理や行動さえも変える力があるのかと衝撃を受けました
それからというもの電車に乗るたびにそれまで意識の抜いていなかった
壁や床の色座席の形
人々の行動にも目が行くようになりました
たった30分
たった30分の番組でデザインというものの
本の数かが一端を知っただけ
私が意識は
世界は
大きく確実に変わりました
かつてへ
教育哲学者の林竹二がー
学んだことの証は只一つで
何かが変わることである
という言葉を残しました
その学びの本質のようなものを楽しさを
私は一瞬のうちに退会したのです
そして
もっとデザインについて深く知ったらそうしたら世界はもっともっと楽しくなるんじゃ
ないか
そう思いました
学びたい知りたいそう強く感じたのは
抗議しんが無性に駆られたノア
その時が初めてだったように思います
デザイナーになりたかったからではなく
デザインについてもっと学びたかったから
その単純の後期人にしたがいい
私は大学でデザインを勉強することに決めました
それまで考えていた進路を白紙撤回して
大学で4年間デザインを学び
実際どうだったか
それはもうすごく楽しかったです
日々新しい知識を持た3毎日
気づき発見が多いめくるめく日々を送りました
そして私の世界はさらに大きく変わりました
こんな風に変わったピューレを一つこの会場に全7方はいないはずなので皆さんが身に
つけている服を0としてみます
馴染みのショッピングモール21
新しい服を買いに行く場面ちょっと想像してみてください
ショップの外観やぺー合う
そこで買い物をしている他のお客さん
定員さん
モールの入り口からそのショップに行くまでの道中にあるお店
思い浮かべることはできるでしょうか
馴染みのショッピングモールといえどもなかなかに難しいことだと思います
こんな風に私たちが普段認識している
意識しているのは
世界の国ごく一部です
そこにあるのに
見えていない
意識の外
それはもはや
存在していないも当然です
これがで残余学び出すと意識の木対象はグーンと広がります
例えば先のショッピングモールを0にすれば商品を一つ一つはもちろん店内に使われて
いる色色の組み合わせ
店やディスプレイがデザインプライスカードの一つ一つにまで意識が向くようになり
ます
さらには
このお店はこのくらいの年代の子の性別で
こんな雑誌を読んでる人をターゲットにしているな
きっとあそこで買い物しテイラーのお客さんはあのブランドも
あんなタイプのジャパンも好きだろうななんていう風に見えてくるんです
自分のタイプじゃないからとスルーしていたお店も
ここは一体どんな人に向けたお店なんだろうかと
想像を巡らせる対象となってきます
自分の身につけた知識をもとにこんな風に推測や想像を巡らせていくのは
さながらシャーロックホームズのようでなかなかに楽しいものです
そのちょっとした楽しさを日々
味わえるだけでも
デザインを学んでよかったなと私は思います
服に限らず今皆さんが身に着けている腕時計やアクセサリーなど
普段使っているノートや件
そしてそれらのパーツ一つ一つも
私たちの世界を構築している
無数の者たちすべて
誰かしらの手によって
デザインされています
デザインを学び
その身のまわりのものたちに1本
一歩近付いてみる
歩み寄ってみると
それぞれの
色や形
昨日に込められた
愛や情熱であったいっ
商品を買わせるための戦略であったり
企業や作り手デザイナーの
様々な
糸や思いに意識が向き
想像をめぐらすことができるようにあります
すると
普段気にも留めていなかった者たちの輪郭が
ぼんやりとした世界の一部だった風景の一部だった者たちが
くっきりと見えてきます
すると目に映る世界は
広く
面白く
味わい深いものになり
何気ない日常の1場面も
なんだか楽しいものになってくるはずです
また
デザインを学ぶ
というのは
デザインをしていく上で必要となってくる
様々な幅広い知識
そしてその応用の仕方それを学ぶことでもあります
その応用の対象を自分の日常に向ければ
日々の暮らしをより良くする
そんなこともできてしまいます
デザインの力です
社会がより良くなるなら
自分の些細な日常をちょっと良くすることくらい
お手のもののはずです
例えばデザインの基本要素でもある色
色の知識広場持つそれぞれのイメージや心理効果を知識として持っていれば
朝服を選ぶときに今日は仕事の打ち合わせだから信頼感を与えたい
じゃあおむめのトーンで寒色系
今用の服を着ていこうであったり今日は味あるな交流会だから親しみやすさを感じて
もらうために赤らめの暖色系
黄色やオレンジ状態の服で行こうかなといった具合に
自分が相手に与える印象を
ちょっとだけ自分の思い通り
自分に有利にできていっ
ときには自分の気持ちを落ち着かせたり
高ぶらせたいっ
他にもいろんな知識は日々のごはんをちょっと美味しそうに見せることもできちゃい
ます
例えばチキンでもポークでも
お肉のグリル料理を作るとなんだか全体的に茶色っぽくって美味しそうに見え
そんな時にはトマトとズッキーニんアプリかも一緒に開いて盛り付けの器は
本色
仕上げにレモンを添えてみてください
デザイン的な言葉で言えば引きそう
色数を増やして重めのトーンで画面を占める
アクセントに捕食を加えるといったところでしょうか
それだけでもご飯ちょっと美味しそうに見えてきます
他にもレイアウトの知識があれば
ノート作り資料づくり応用することもできます
見やすいノートで勉強の効率が良くなったり
仕事をしていく上でも営業の資料や内部資料か
見やすい伝わりやすいに越したことはないですよね
そんな日常のささいなことも
すべて立派なデザインだと
私は思います
そしてその日常を自分の手でちょっとよくできる
そのデザインの力は
誰しもが持っていてもいいものではないのかなと思うのです
皆さんの中には特にファッションや料理に関しては
感覚的にできてしまう人も多いのではないかと思います
その感覚的なものを知識として学ぶと
ある程度公式か
マニュアル化をすることができるようにあります
学べば学ぶほど自分の手札は増え
日常の中であれこの公式ってここにも使えるなという場面が増えます
応用の幅
ちょっとよくできる物事がだんだん多くなるのです
私自身はその対象が自分の日常から
自分の生まれ育った地域伊豆修善寺8なり
地元をデザインの力でちょっと良くしたい
その思い出
2017年
大学4年生の時に
修善寺つば名車という
地域密着型のデザインスタジオと直営の物販店舗
修善寺の温泉街に構えました
これまでの2年間は日々店頭に立ち
地域の方々や観光客の皆さんの声を聞き
地元だした感じるお土産物のデザイン
地域在住のサッカーを結びつけての商品のプロデュースをしたり
野外手作り市や訪日外国人に向けた
も食の料理教室などのイベント
その規格と
関連するツールのデザインそして実際の運営に取り組んできました
2年経った今でも地元のおじいちゃんおばあちゃんからは雑貨屋さんの店長さん
もしくは a を書いていることを仕事にしている子
そんな風に思われています
それも仕事の一部ではありますが
人の流れお金の流れを常に見せ
地域に根ざしたこと作りものづくりで地域の活性化をそっと支えていく
地域そのものをデザインしていくちょっと良くしていく
それが私の仕事です
もちろん
デザインを学んだからこそ今はデザイナーとして仕事をしています
しかしかつての私自身がそうであったように
デザインを学ぶということは
デザイナーになる方法を学ぶということと決してイコールではありません
デザインを学ぶと
目に映る世界は
広く
面白く
味わい深いものになります
そして自分の日常を明日をちょっとよくできる
そんな素敵な力を手に入れることもできてしまいます
そしてその素敵なデザインという力
デザイナーと呼ばれる一握りの人が使えるような特殊な力ではなく
誰にでも
あなたにでも
手にできる力です